orientation is locked rotate the device
back
there we go
rainbow doesn't seem very stable now I
gotta figure out the gimbal
should we start there we go
oh that was pretty cool
I'll rotate again okay there we go what
oh this isn't a vertical
okay
gimbals
I think there's a block there we go what
oh this isn't a vertical strip
oh there's another audio
gimbles
can you see it
on what on your phone oh
yeah oh yeah you're like yeah but it's
the orientation right
[Music]
huh
well anyways hello who everyone's here
that's why Friday maybe
we're flipping everything on its head
just like our prices
uh no it's still still okay so should
this just be a vertical stream
it's a vertical stream now
fast forward
is
oh now we're straight okay oh they want
Shane
let's take a quick tour of the open
pilot office Shane there
still a little web team
all right guys so we are hiring in most
teams we'll start off with a quick uh
quick little tour of uh the whole new
office space
see uh the the great workplace you might
be able to work at
Kurt Kurt our new GPS expert
Cameron shipped our new website last
week pretty cool so working on lots of
connect features for you guys and then
uh you guys all know Shane over there
he's working on car stuff
hard at work right now
and then the testing closet
and uh just a reminder that we're gonna
win
the legend uh the legend himself sits by
the wind sign
that's how many Secrets did we showing
all the whiteboards uh none
our beautiful wall of uh metrics see
this shows all the failures
oh the Christmas in there
what's up Chris
you can come play ping pong here oh yeah
this is our Super Hyper competitive ping
pong room
the level used to be very very low when
we got the table but at times have since
changed and now
everyone takes it very seriously
all right should we make our way over to
the rest of the tour should go
downstairs or we should finish upstairs
uh I can show for operations just walk
around and we can show off the gym oh
yeah yeah let's let's show them our new
gym if you guys might remember bathroom
land
for most teams so if you if you like
what we do you're interested in working
here please check out if there's a good
fit for you
so our work in progress gym
you wanna say hi
this is very exciting I didn't even know
about this room
there's just so many rooms of this
office
[Music]
thing yeah
sure
she ain't trying to stuff thank you
yeah oh my God we got yoga tomorrow
I didn't realize that thing goes
and you can see our Courtyard down here
our Christmas tree is going right there
all right all right we are hiring
now we're still working our way over
there oh they're having ice cream on the
way
oh the department hacks a little sad
right now yeah but somebody can come
here and build a great Department of
hacks
yeah we had this grandiose idea to have
a room dedicated to employee side
projects but as you can see it's just
become a storage unit we've been hard at
work it's on zero nine for you guys I
thought there wasn't that much time for
side projects but hopefully that'll
change
a little run through
you can take them downstairs yeah let's
uh let's go down so what's your plan
indeed should we talk to Hardware team
uh yeah unless there's they had a
hardware team
all right Harvard team's downstairs
all right but so deep what's the plan
we're gonna go downstairs we're gonna
check out production yeah we're gonna
see all the cool stuff they're doing
we're gonna get a new device and here's
our keys we're gonna get it into a car
and we're gonna have a customer
experience yeah
oh we should start off with the website
we can do that downstairs yeah
do they have any questions so far if you
have any questions about zero nine
uh I just see a comment that says zero
nine adult question
there's never been a better time to buy
uh common trees it's a pretty incredible
deal new version lower price
is more somebody says this isn't Twitter
HQ no it is not
is that the Corolla oh Shane brought it
out in front for us
I think you're supposed to use a
joystick yeah
oh that's cool
I don't know about the nav model
we can talk about the nav
all righty close the door
all right here's the devices you will
not get if you ordered our Black Friday
these will go back and be fixed
this is production team
should we started circuits book yeah
let's go all right
too much
so circuit spoke is uh there's some real
amazing it's some real a real production
line conveyor belts you're just going to
put parts in and come after you come out
yeah
all right so it actually starts over
here
Victor is programming our jet printer
and then devices uh oh it'd be cool if
we had a device in each state but
this is a little hard to turn
so devices start out here
they get the solder paste jet printed on
and then they go over to the pick and
place
is all the components
and then over to the oven on this
conveyor belt
all the way to our
turn
all the way over to the aoi where they
get inspected
you can see the line is rolling right
now very slowly oh my God I didn't
realize it was already operational
no we're not using boards from the line
yet
um can you give us the rundown of zero
nine we'll do that in the car
what else good vegan we do have vegan
food actually yeah we've got pretty good
vegetarian food I don't know it's vegan
and vegetarian the same so our vegans
yes
come
new head office we only have one this
this is the head off yes
he's pretty cool
it'll take lots of pictures of your
comma three all the lenses switch out
super fast
make sure everything's working
oh that's our custom 3D printer board
s
yeah
oh I think they're having their meeting
right now
maybe we shouldn't disturb them too much
all right
okay
quickly walks away all right this is
where your devices get built
yeah and the drive
yeah
all right and then shall we pick up a
device should we still in the process
should we start at the website and then
we'll go and pick it up I mean we know
how to buy something all right
fair enough I just wanted to show off
the new website
but uh we do have a new website check
out our new website I mean we buy them
right here
and we've got
our first Common threes being fulfilled
for Black Friday
Ada where can we uh take advice
pretend we just bought one
where can we take one bin we don't like
it we'll return it uh they want to know
which bin they can take one out of one
way whichever
um so we got a basic Edition
what's the difference between all the
storage variants
all right great we got a brand new one
new device we're going to show you guys
the first install experience
and then we'll go for our zero nine
drive and we'll talk about the details
yeah so we're going to use the widen cam
on this I mean I totally tried that and
that was technical difficulties yeah
I'm gonna show them the fleet
so more ev6 starter yeah a Chevy bolts
our beautiful Taco Bell car over here
about
and four weeks time
oh okay
all right
and this is
all right we should figure out how to
rotate too
let's figure that out okay
it's your very first setup
okay
we got a brand new device brand new
device still got the screen protector on
so I'm just going to plug this in and uh
see what happens oh it's just a store
more driving data
for your dash cam videos and such no
performance implications
all right I plugged in I'm just gonna
drive outside because the security guard
is very confused
wake up here
yeah 24 hour security
oh
I should stop over there oh but we got a
Wi-Fi range maybe we should just make a
right
[Music]
so maybe
it's uh
[Laughter]
all right we got the Wi-Fi put in all
righty what happens now
I don't think I've ever done this
procedure all right now click continue
continue
of course we want to install custom
software custom software
alrighty
let's do that
what now openbattle.com without AI
openpile.com
wow this is really simple and that's all
the users have to do that's it after
they pay 18.49 on the store yep where is
the Accord the cord is back in the
parking garage
is there an option for in-person pickup
no
as we can have time to receive uh
clients we've only got 15 employees
oh wait it's already installed
yeah I told you it was fast zero nine is
great virtually Chris might come out of
retirement
nice okay looking forward to the videos
all terms and conditions this is the
smoothest growing part I opened variety
agree begin training
boom boom I've done this before guys you
guys should read what's going on I know
what I'm doing
tap on the alert
not on the alert
yes I want to upload my data tap on the
max speed how fast can you ship we ship
same day two-day shipping just like
Amazon press the pedal
all right finish training all right are
we good to go no we gotta we're on chill
mode
on experimental mode
um yeah let's do experimental mode oh
they say take the plastic off they can't
see the screen okay let's take the
plastic off look at that that's
beautiful
I feel kind of bad doing that such a
beautiful screen I don't know let's use
the uh let's go through the normal flow
on the off-road what's the normal turn
off the car oh you haven't gone through
this have you
no let's see what's going on there's a
click on it on what oh it is yeah oh
okay wow this is cool
all right I'm out of chill mode Let's Do
It experimental
new driving visualization end-to-end
control yes please uh it turns red oh my
God look at it we're on experimental
mode
are we ready to go we're ready to go
let's go for it
or drive
when you think the knee will be ready to
ship fortunately not super soon
and unfortunately some other priorities
are
taking that over for a while but I think
you guys will enjoy the results
yeah do you guys have any more feedback
on zero nine or questions about that are
you going to sell that unit after the
Stream
we'll uh fix it up and give it back to
production
[Music]
because you're not like a battle with
comma two no
comma three only
so we are waiting for it to calibrate
it's pretty quick calibrates really fast
now
there used to be a time years ago when I
think it was like a 40-minute Highway
Drive was required to get it to
calibrate
it was really embarrassing and then you
accidentally reset calibration and you
go to drive another 40 minutes
but uh no longer by the time we're on
the highway should be good
I mean someone asked to go navigate on
open pilot I guess should we talk about
that
yeah let's talk about
so yeah one of the future so there's
really three big features that we've
been working on for the last you know
that's like kind of the plan which is
the first is end-to-end collateral
planning so it steers like a human that
we've already fully shipped that's been
shipped for a few releases now then
end-to-end longitudinal planning so I
can control the gas and it breaks like a
human that's been what we've been
focusing on for the last few months and
that's what experimental enables
and then the last one is navigate on
open pilot so we would want to you know
humans look at the map to know where
they're going oh is there no map no
we didn't set up Prime well we don't
have Prime so we don't have a map on
this device to show but once you have uh
do you need to make sure you calibrate
on a road with clean Lane line no
as long as it says calibrated you're all
good
so the way the calibration works is it
just looks at the way the car is moving
and uh can know kind of the orientation
of how it's set up assuming that cars
generally move forward
it works everywhere all the time
as long as the camera can see the road
so we're not enabled in end-to-end Long
mode so it's doing everything it's
steering it's deciding how fast the
drive
a few updates it's uh kind of useful I
think it's super useful on the Corolla
so let's see how this goes
we're trying to go to uh
somewhere in the downtown oh it really
doesn't want to rotate
[Music]
maybe we can kill the street and restart
all right guys we'll come back in a
second
you can't really see that much all right
all right we're back I don't seems fixed
okay
and
you can pay us to fix it for you for a
100 lever
so it'll just be cost to Parts Plus
labor or you can do the repair yourself
or just the cost of the hearts it's live
on the shop right now if you wanna go
check it out
but basically if we show the map of the
navigation of where you're driving the
same one that you can use in the comma 3
UI to get where you're going we just
show them all that map and we can tell
the model
that's where you want to go and I should
kind of figure it out by itself we're
kind of working on that on the side
right now uh there's uh some branches
open but they're not really close to
being very functional yet we're still
kind of
but that's how we're planning to get to
Taco Bell put in the Taco Bell
destination press engage and the rest
will just happen by itself
um what else do they need to know do
they have any questions does the lane
change use the blind spot sensors yes
it'll block on them right now
um eventually we'll start using the
decam for that and some Corner Radars on
cars that have it
but yeah it'll prevent you from making
the light change if it takes the car
there on the cars I have them
how many of you guys have comma threes
right now
what's your ETA on Taco now as usual
there's no ETA we would love to know too
one taco nav no just on taco
oh I mean you know the deadline was the
end of the year we're very motivated to
get there
but as you can see we're really working
pretty hard we've got uh
longitudinal shift and experimental mode
[Music]
um
[Music]
steak
foreign
interesting place to drive
it's kind of improvisation without the
nav
I got more questions about zero nine no
not yeah you guys have a question about
zero nine zero nine one
the Black Friday sale this is the
cheapest time ever to buy comma three so
get him all you can or if you're
thinking about applying for a job you
have any questions this is the time for
questions
here uh Pilots deciding how fast to
drive 55 is a pretty reasonable some guy
asked us to slow down on curves it's
slowing down right now yeah it's slowing
down I mean the lead's quite far away so
that's not really what's deciding the
speed right now it's just entering long
thinks this is a good speed for this uh
this part of the road yeah usually it
would like lose the lead in a curve
accelerate a little bit catch it and you
would have these big discontinuity so we
don't have uh navigate a no pilot here
so we're we have to take
ourselves
and then this is a really hard part this
is what we'll likely still have to
improve in the future it's like slowing
down on the off-ramp but I mean I'm not
actually pretty good here yeah we'll see
It'll take this off stop sign
okay
it wouldn't it's a good up road map
correct and zero nine means feature
complete
uh
I mean pretty feature complete we know
what everything looks like right now I
mean there's only really been three big
things that we're working on which is
like uh navigate on open pilot and twin
lateral and went long and
we've shipped into it long now in an
experimental mode and we're working on
Navigator and that's that's what we
consider like feature complete no match
is not coming stop asking about it yes
you could set the destination from your
phone
well it's the greatest Edge case you've
seen so far in user data
[Music]
there's a lot of edge cases
will it swerve around cyclists Maybe
uh it's getting a lot better at that
kind of stuff like making making good uh
lateral decisions and moving around for
Stuff
[Music]
the URL to install 09 is open
is there a revised talk about right from
the new office
same route
dip how do you train nav from Gregor
um so we trained that by just uh
inputting the map of the image and then
ground truthing it on that
so so we show it where the user went
we tell it if the user wanted to go
there there's our first red light and
down for yellow here we go that's very
human-like
comfortable stuff look at that Antoine
Long last night I had it to an
unprotected left turn it was pretty cool
crept up a little bit stopped and then
went
not sure why it's creeping up now but
thanks
sometimes it doesn't go
um yeah should we start with the image
we showed the navigation that the uh
that would have taken it where the user
ended up going and then we say given
this navigation input left here
given that information
um then just plan the best thing to
match the human trajectory and that will
just work with nav so that's how we
grounded it and um
we've got some experimental branches at
work but we're
we're still fixing some bugs hopefully
that'll be pretty good soon
some guy asks he had a comma too he
tried it out but the follow distance was
too long so we've since shortened it
um but with end to end it should just be
once we
have more conservative lead policy it
should be pretty human-like yeah I mean
the promise is just it's hard to
find something that's not too long in in
all situations and not too short in all
situations so it's a bit nuanced but end
to end is really good at getting those
differences so it should feel a lot more
comfortable all the time
well different Drive modes ever be
created Beyond chill and experimental so
yes but so chill and experimental are
they're not quite driver aggressiveness
profiles they're more uh if you want the
polished experience or do you want to
try the bleeding edge stuff
um so we'll have another thing on top of
that that'll allow you to select
um that'll be somewhat like a follow
distance but it'll be uh aggressiveness
kind of slider
yeah so this is this here right here is
a really good example of the kind of
stuff that oh oh and just stuff for the
orange light
could either you eventually read the OEM
followed its in settings and adjust the
follow distance
[Music]
um
so I mean that doesn't really have
anything to do with n10 long it's more
of like an experienced question and
until now
this is how we've uh designed the
experience
oh the Corolla yeah you have to click
resume if you engage at a stop it's a
Corolla thing we should show an alert
but yeah this is the kind of stuff that
it's really improved a lot in zero nine
like moving over for these stopped cars
kind of avoiding these cones before it
was a lot more lazy and kind of reacting
to these obstacles around but you can
see it's planning it really well here
the set speed is 45 it's driving a
reasonable 21.
yeah then we got that other light coming
up does it stop it stops as well yeah
it'll do everything it just drives the
uh an appropriate speed and from that
you got stop signs lights slowing down
for turns I mean it's still like it
makes mistakes still quite frequently
and the easier the situation is the less
likely it's going to be to make mistakes
like these really clear intersections
like these ones are the ones that
struggle the least with
but this is slowing down a little bit
too much right now but I mean it's still
comfortable
like the speed limit here was 30 and it
was driving 20. now it's accelerating
back up
it's definitely not perfect but uh in a
lot of cases it makes pretty sensible
decisions I mean it's definitely more
chill than you know the ACC policy which
would just accelerate to your set speed
yeah every now and again I have it on
the wrong mode and I engage and it just
accelerates I'm like oh no it's broken
but it turns out that's just
that's just ACC policy I don't know
and then some guy asked again what the
different storage means it's just for
your dash cam video so if you don't
care too much about that just go for the
basic Edition it'll work exactly the
same for open pilot
yeah any other questions
has anyone tried out the end-to-end long
yeah this guy says Excel is great
oh the new Excel from stop yeah
yeah we did fix that in this release a
lot of people were complaining about how
slowly accelerated from a stop and so we
we bumped up the uh low speed
acceleration for the ACC policy so
hopefully that fixes some people's
experience
does it read and adjust speed to current
speed limit sign so again it doesn't
explicitly do any of this it looks at
the picture the same thing you look at
and it just chooses a speed to drive
yeah yeah so in these last few
um
last last 10 minutes or so it's been
selecting the speed the whole time and I
can just tell by looking at the scene
you know the parked cars around the road
all that it knows what's a good speed to
drive is you don't you don't need to
tell it to read the speed limit signs or
anything like that yeah so I see a lot
of specific uh questions about like very
particular scenarios
um we don't look at any of that stuff
um it'll just slowly get better at more
nuanced scenarios
as we refine it it should just kind of
do something that's generally correct
but maybe it won't be super comfortable
right now
I want the drive data to create the emmc
chip no so we tested this the uh we
tested the flash really extensively
before we started shipping the Basic
Editions
um I wouldn't be concerned about that at
all
you you would have to be driving for
years and years before you even start to
be concerned about that
[Music]
um what else
yeah and turned long it's supposed to be
a lot better in like stop and go traffic
kind of in the situation because it
accelerates much harder when necessary
and there's also more chill when it sees
it's like more of a stop and go scene
[Music]
is the inside camera able to see outside
the driver and passenger side windows
yes
definitely love zero nine and ten long
slowing down stop signs are Hit or Miss
yeah that's our experience too
yeah I think it's really quite good if
you use it uh properly
if you don't uh just try to let it take
every stop sign it'll generally kind of
slow down and then if it's not going to
stop in time or if it's doing something
you wouldn't do just take over and then
re-engage
taking over and re-engaging should
always be very comfortable
how did you cut the model training Time
by days
oh I mean yeah
cutting the model Trend so now I have to
press resume oh yeah you gotta press
resume if you engage it'll stop with the
Corolla oh I see if you can get your
stuff yeah yeah so cutting the model
training time was a very very long
project we probably that was probably a
main focus for about six months or so
what we were doing is we had many many
training steps that be it graduated into
over time so we were training maybe four
models and one had to train and then we
had to run that model and all the data
and then the next one had to train and
it would just all the training times it
originally took long there were many
steps and so we just kind of
re-architected the system with all the
steps removed and then spent around six
months actually trying to ship this
re-architected system there was just so
many subtle bugs and differences and
things that we ended up seeming to rely
on even though that wasn't intentional
but so that was a that was a huge
project to just kind of simplify the
architecture reduce the total steps and
then on top of that we upgraded to a new
data center with much more compute and
improved our info structure so it used
to compute
so it was a very big thing it wasn't
like one trick a month so very hard work
from infrastructure machine learning and
everyone
yeah it's very exciting now we're
shipping models almost every week
sometimes multiple models a week so the
pace of improvement is really pretty
incredible yeah I mean we went from
Shipping like a couple models in a whole
year to over the last month we've
probably merged five new models
so um it's really paid off these like
six months of really hard work and
improving the flow you want to talk
about some of the cool tests we have
like the uh the hugging test the like
speed convergence test
uh yeah sure so
one of the reasons that we're able to
iterate through malls really quickly and
ship them with some amount of confidence
that they will improve things we have a
huge test Suite that test both in Carla
and in our own simulator that uses real
data they simulate certain scenarios and
they change a few factors they check how
the open pilot will drive if you give it
certain issues like we can introduce the
steering wheel lag which some cars have
we can introduce like steering wheel
noise and so we can check how openpilot
drives in all these different conditions
with noise without noise with lag
um and then we can build up some amount
of confidence that it will drive well
the real world and now for rent went
long we've got uh similar tests for
traffic lights stop signs uh all in in
both Carla and in our own simulation
stack
and that means that you know you can
make a change and you can kind of look
at this entire Suite of tests and kind
of build up a picture of how open pilot
will drive without ever having to
actually get into a car which is
incredibly inefficient
you can see cones it's uh well pretty
close but
made around that's something we had in
previous releases we were trying to get
get it to be better at just detecting my
cones and obstacles is something that's
historically
so we got a few questions doing more
work on RAM yes we got a lot of new cars
recently so we're kind of just going
down the list
but yeah expect the ram to get a lot
better
kind of I'll be trying to press the
resume so you're probably talking about
GM yeah we'll fix up the GM
why do we get torque limits so often
with the latest two models on knft which
car are you talking about
[Music]
um I bought a comma two two to three
years ago what tangible benefits would I
actually see by upgrading to a comma
three
I mean this is it it's chill driving on
city streets I mean if you're on the
last stable comma 2 release there's
really actually quite a lot of
differences between uh comma three and
uh comma two
we've obviously shipped these like
experimental features now with Android
long let me just stopped at this stopped
light by itself
but the lateral control has improved so
much we have now very good systems that
automatically tuning for most platforms
the steering wheel is super precise it
used to be
turkey
fixed so many different cars
yeah I think there's just so many
improvements across the whole stack that
either like subtly improve the
experience eliminate bugs and then
there's like the major stuff like this
end-to-end long thing I mean just check
out the release notes um and the blog
post for this release it's really
predictable
um
see what else release
I mean so we've just been engaged for
like five minutes now
stoplight
there's been obstacle
was on the road there's been cones
they're pretty reliable one guy asked us
to take in multiple frames yes takes in
two frames
it takes in two frames at a time and
then it takes in the wide Cam and the
narrow cam as well and then it also has
a history buffer itself so I can
remember stuff
was the U-turn manual yes
so yeah the the for the cases where we
had to make like decisions like making
turns or exits that's manual for now
until we have Navigator and open pallet
but on this whole Road here where
there's been like cars parked a little
bit in the lane and there's been stop
lights and all the speed selection
that's all been fully automatic so here
it's going to come up to a stoplight
again that should be no problem
I was gimbal is so hard to use all right
trust us nobody's touching anything it's
stopping for this flight I mean you
don't have to trust us it's the cheapest
time ever to buy a comma three buy a
comma three if you don't have one if you
don't have a supported car you can just
rent a car buy a comma 3 and if you
don't want to keep it you can send it
back return shipping is paid for that's
actually a good idea for your comma 2
users for asking what the difference is
I mean if you don't see the difference
return it it's you got 30 days yeah it's
easy enough to just drop in it's uh same
harness and everything
all right so no questions asked
just uh give it a shot return return
shipping is paid for so it's a really no
hassle experience I think it's all
automatic too you don't have to talk to
anybody
if you always wanted to try it and
you're going on a road trip and renting
a car just rent a Toyota Corolla that's
supported get a you a comma three try it
out what's the fork though it's not a
fork so it's openpile.com this is stock
open pilot zero nine we're driving on
the release
master has already got a new model but
uh we'll save that for next time yeah no
this is all uh completely standard stuff
uh no no weird one-off discounts for
fifteen hundred dollars that was a
one-time thing
I don't even know how to do that
I'm not figuring it out
um
can't recommend a C3 enough
way better than C2
uh is e2e just one single model that
does it all yep just one single model
that does it all
so it's trained in a simulation and we
simulate all these all conditions in the
one training run
uh lateral noise longitudinal noise and
that's it shipping same day yes we're
shipping every day not just this week we
always ship every day two-day shipping
immediate fulfillment installed now
so tries to avoid cones and parked cars
what about people or anything else I
mean we don't really distinguish between
these things the harder it is to see the
more open pilot will struggle but in
general oh I'm gonna take over here
resume
it's a Corolla work so this is the first
disengagement over these last uh five to
ten minutes and several stop lights and
obstacles and everything so
give you an idea of kind of where the
end-to-end long is that it's on on
easiest roads it's uh it's relatively
reliable
and the the rest is uh gonna come soon
[Music]
okay I also don't know where I'm
took my C3 to Italy this summer Edie
will never figure out how they're
driving style works
foreign
[Music]
might do better than you someday
let me try to get out of the city
[Music]
what else we got are there any more
questions so doesn't even have questions
about working in karma do you train your
models also uh yes we train models oh
whoops I don't understand what that
question means oh on EU roads uh yeah so
we've got majority American and Canadian
data but uh we do upweight the uh
the importance of non-us and Canada data
in the training set so that we can get a
bit more driving style diversity in
there we've got users all over the place
China South Korea Japan Nigeria
India all over the place so that's all
in the data set it's obviously it's I
think around 50 American Canada now and
50 the rest
anyone have a comma 2 and they're still
having doubts about buying comma 3 today
how is Greg's work on torque limits
helping with OP
I don't really know what that means
comma Brazil says Brazil That's cool
we'll just call my Brazil do
what's that is that a comma Europe
I think there's one guy that drives a
lot in Brazil it's definitely been seen
him in the data set
uh
[Music]
I would go check out the Brazil office
that sounds cool
what are you rocking there 20 20 Corolla
or is it 2019 I think 2019
yeah it's a TSA sticker roller so
probably 20 20 maybe 2019. yeah I think
this is our most popular platform right
if you include the hybrid I mean yeah if
you just look at the top ones and you
merge the cruel I think if you merge all
the Toyotas and RAV4 still on top oh
really yeah but Corolla previous RAV4
all up there
all right well there's a lot of cones
here in the city today this is a real
real uh really putting the stream to the
test here but
didn't didn't hit them
we're fine went through a yellow light
[Music]
if there's some confusing Lane markers
on the road
doesn't even flinch
yeah no I think you guys will be
impressed with zero nine it's in lateral
it's really a lot better at all these
nuanced situations like cones or faded
Lane lines or kind of the road starts
curving just slightly s turns that stuff
has gotten so much better in this
release
so you guys will find that exciting
any ideas on displaying converged
Auto-Tune
oh we talked about that this morning
uh
this is tricky
we want to visualize something but we're
not I'm not exactly sure yet how how or
what so but it's it's on our uh it's on
our roadmap does Edie do anything with
speed bumps actually yes uh probably
slows down a little bit too much
um but yeah it does see them right now
if red lights are working that might be
enough for me to upgrade I appreciate
the stream guys I mean red lights
are probably a reason to get you in but
you'll notice all the subtle things and
you'll just it'll feel a lot better
um these things are just really hard to
communicate on the highway it should
still be a lot more comfortable yeah and
confident
the steering has gotten so much smoother
we've spent a huge amount of effort over
the last uh probably roughly 12 months
getting the steering from being like
good enough that it will take the turns
and everything relatively well to really
feeling like that kind of superhuman
smooth control
um
and if you've got a car that's recently
gotten tour control which is our like
new way of controlling the cars you'll
definitely notice a huge Improvement
I think internally that was the biggest
like feeling of whoa this is a big
Improvement in a while everyone that
drove on it was like damn this feels so
much more human-like and smooth
maybe we should have done that zero
eight seven release uh like the launch
comma three release versus zero nine
that would have been cool to do on
stream yeah but you guys can all try it
out I think you'll be uh surprised how
big of a difference there is
see how it accelerates here to the um
so the highway speeds
I'm mostly kind of impressed with how
well the end time I told you the Corolla
is really good
you've got to believe me now that the
Optima has the best steering I mean it
failed on one of the stoplights and
everything else like 10 stop lights it
did Super smoothly very human-like
picked a good Speed Most of the time
like this is very very good here 45
miles an hour it feels super in control
yeah
it's slowing down here normally wouldn't
do that
what's the next toggle to be added and
or removed I have two I want to remove
but uh they're not super easy I want to
remove Lane departure warnings and and
uh reset calibration button
but uh I really want to pull the trigger
on a C3 right now but my biggest issue
is disabled a b when doing long on my
Hyundai well but you you don't have to
drive with that necessarily you can just
uh use the stock ACC I mean it'll still
provide a lot of value
I mean yeah this ede long stuff on your
Santa Fe is probably also not good
enough to daily drive so you can always
just flick it on for a couple drives try
it out and then hopefully you know we
have something to replace it soon enough
so it's always a choice it's an easy
toggle
yeah compared to like the stock Hyundai
systems open power is a lot smoother
online
I can vouch for ede light handling wet
Road avoiding puddles Etc most of the
time on zero 13.
I hate the lane departure warnings well
you can turn them off I want to make
them good and turn them always on
the data on how many actually use the
lane departure toggle yes I think it's
like 25 percent
PD breaking feels really jerky on the
Civic Toyota long delay probably Smooths
it out it says Chris
yeah that is possible there's really
quite a few differences in the in the
long control
we're working on kind of unifying it a
lot currently we've mostly been focusing
on the Toyotas in the Hyundai's just
waiting on eating a long slash a b issue
to go to C3 so I'd say ede long is good
enough for you to you know be excited
and have a comma three I wouldn't really
wait on the a b issue I mean it's
like I said it's a toggle you can try
out you had to add long when you want
and then just go back to stock ACC
um but I mean hopefully you're engaged
and a b is essentially uh if you have
cruise control
so largely mitigates the need
so I mean the hope is you'll be largely
engaged with Anton long and then
um a b shouldn't really be a concern in
those scenarios so uh oh pilot also does
have four Collision warnings
I don't know
use those but if there is a case where
owned by the things that cannot break in
time but there should be more braking uh
you'll get a red alarm
my friend is buying a Tesla with FSD
will I be able to one-up him with a C3
on a 22 Camry I think so I think it's uh
I mean it's not quite an FSD like
experience it's uh I think experimental
mode is still pretty chill
um certainly more chill than FSD
but uh definitely does some cool things
when are you going to get another VW
Audi uh actually Ford is next Maybe
for this week I don't know about VW Audi
is Albert Einstein monitoring blind
spots on his Lane changes solicited no
[Music]
questions
for the exclamation point yes we're
excited too
and that should have long pretty soon
we can do long at the camera
long and Chevy we have a bolt
man everybody clicks bolt on the website
it's uh
I know people love the Chevy bolt that
what do you guys think of the new
website too
yeah that's a good question can Edie
break as hard as stuck ACC so yeah we
have the iso limits uh same as your
stock ACC
o self-drive soon
[Music]
no no opinions on the website
like this it's a great website I know
I'm very proud of it new site is too
green does it have that much green
new website is nice ordering harness
will be nice if I had a search yeah
we're working on a web team is working
on it does anybody else want to come
here and work on web stuff
Shane had to uh
do a shift as the web engineer last week
he wasn't super excited about it he's
back on cars this week
love the new site thanks for the hard
hard work guys
it was all straight and Cameron
what do the people think of the new
price
hey you web stuff no our web stuff is
gonna be nice Cameron's working really
hard on connect it's a lot of behind the
scenes stuff
he's uh doing an incredible job
whoa what's going on there
again
Old Town pests
C2 and C3 use the same Mountain no but
like if you're super excited and you got
your comma 3 it'll work but you should
probably switch them up there's just a
small part of the white Cam view that is
obscured by the old man he's Edie long
using Vision only so
the end time policy is but it also has
the rate it falls back to the old lead
policy which uses radar
Volkswagen policy can support well it's
cruise control
any way to support I'm not sure go ask
in the VW Channel we have a great
Volkswagen maintainer who knows
everything about Volkswagens
[Music]
goes for the stop sign
it's really pretty human-like do you
think there's a point where radar isn't
going to be needed soon uh yes we it's
so good that we haven't written the
radar parser for our ub6 yet
yeah we then turn long a lot of the need
for the radar will kind of go away
the reason the radar is necessary is
just it's the easy way to write uh this
is the cruise control is to use the
radar with the incredibly accurate lead
speeds and then to write some simple
logic but that's not how humans decide
to drive on the highway
all right guys
I'm the first drive on new C3
back at the office
uh
does it look for oncoming traffic to go
to stop sign
I mean it's all
again
also that radar tested quite a bit
recently yeah it works really quite well
I was hoping I wanted to go during a
four-way stop sign
uh sometimes
it'll be long for a Honda boss supported
in experimental longitudinal mode yes
but yeah that still needs some more to
be smooth what's the web stack
github.comai connect
go check it out
uh
any more questions
[Music]
is that it guys
any more zero nine questions what's
coming up
zero nine experiences
well if that's all they got all right
guys
buy a coma three
if you don't like get send it back it's
gonna be cheaper than it's ever going to
be biggest sale ever
what do my comma points do
uh I'm not really sure they look nice
you should be very proud I have a lot of
comma points I'm very proud of them just
go live more often but what do you want
to know
this wasn't I feel like this uh we
didn't tell you guys that much we'll do
a q a every now and again if you guys
have questions okay we just didn't get
that many questions I travel for work
how easy to temporarily switch to a
rental car uh I'd say the hardest part
is probably removing them out but if
you've got a nice like workflow for that
then it's really quite easy
um extra cameras needed for full
self-driving
uh we'll see we should be able to make
uh Lane changes with the blind spot
Monitor and the interior can pretty
relaxing this guy says bye I think it's
done all right see you guys